when do you cut your losses or give up
on something and walk when and how to
decide to cut bait not a quitter
too much brain damage brain damage it's
a word I've been hearing more for the
corporate world actually as people talk
about what something's really hard to do
and they're just causing brain damage by
trying to do it and this was actually
two questions that's up it's a metaphor
obviously yeah yeah it's okay it's a
metaphor for it and it's a metaphor for
what I talked about when I was like a
beating my head against the old rickets
yes and this is one of those things that
confuses people because everyone here is
including us in the SEAL Teams we hear
the mantra of never never quit right
never quit and it's not just a mantra
that we say it's actually it's actually
what we believe yeah and furthermore
it's not just what we say and it's not
just what we believe but it's literally
how we act yeah so that that drive of
that attitude of never quit it's a
powerful force and it does push you over
the edge to victory to victory in many
cases but and there's always a dichotomy
to just about everything there's a
dichotomy to this too
because over that attitude you have to
layer something on top of that and that
is basically strategic vision and
understanding of the battlefield as a
whole
so you know it's like the the the saying
of win the battle lose the war this is
the opposite right win the battle lose
the war meaning oh you you stick to it
right now and you might win right now
but in the long run you're going
this is the opposite where you you're
gonna say you know what I'm gonna lose
this battle right now yeah but I'm gonna
win the war in the long run so you
absolutely need to know when you gotta
stop beating your head against the wall
you've got to know that I personally
draw my limit at 27 times after I beat
my head against the wall 27 times on the
28th time I'm gonna say you know what
I'll bet there's another way to do this
or won't maybe this isn't a battle worth
fighting now the main reason I think why
people get caught in the trap of banging
their head against the wall or not
knowing when to quit is because it again
quite is a strong word and it's almost
hard for me to say right now because
it's not knowing when to quit I'm not
talking about quitting yeah talking
about yeah I know I'm talking about
making a strategic assessment of an
unwinnable situation and deciding to
disengage only so you can re-engage with
superior firepower and crush the enemy
so there's a big difference between that
and quitting quitting means you curl up
into a ball and wait to die that's where
the wedding is and I don't support that
under any circumstances so when do you
when does it happen where it happens
because people get emotional they get
too emotional about whatever it
obstacles in front of them they get
crazy about it and they start seeing the
obstacle as not only the battle but also
as the war and they get lost in their
own determination I've seen this with
some seal buddies in mind they're so
determined that they will not stop even
when it's completely detrimental
you know and they do it with just about
everything you know they'll be
determined that anything you know
they'll be hurting themselves training
they'll be you know determined to drink
harder than anybody else though I mean
just anything you can throw out up and
they're determined to win at that and
you're actually losing yeah so so how do
you prevent that from happening is you
have to again common theme here you have
to detach you have to detach yourself
you have to be able to step back away
from the problem enough to look at it
from a strategic viewpoint and say okay
what's what's going on here what's the
wit risk what's the reward how much am I
willing to sacrifice right now and how
is that sacrifice gonna impact me
tomorrow or the next day or next week
yeah and then once you've detached and
you've weighed and you've seen what the
real value of the this immediate
objective is then you can assess and
make a logical decision based not on
your emotion but on the actual impact of
the situation in the overall strategic
picture yeah then I you're saying when
you weigh that the the detriment and the
rewards and I think that that really
makes it real clear when you can assess
and be like oh all of this we're getting
all this like all these this detrimental
stuff when we're trying to get this you
know this one right benefit you know out
of this person or out of this situation
or whatever and when you're you're using
up your resources or sacrificing more
resources then you are gaining ground
then you know that that seems like a
clearer time to at the very least start
thinking about disengaging yeah and you
got it you got a detached appeal no
decided I noticed this in jujitsu all
the time people try and pass the Pasig
artist externalist example yeah people
just like do one guard pass yeah and it
doesn't work and they do it again and it
doesn't work and they do it again it
doesn't work they do and they go on and
on and on until they're exhausted is
whether they get mounted and then they
get put to
and it's because they were stubborn and
they didn't detach and say I mean after
you've tried to pass a guy's guard 14
times in a row the same way and it
hasn't worked why is it gonna work the
15th time the answer is it's not try
something else it's the same thing you
should see this putting seals through
training they'd get like bogged down in
a bad situation and they would um they
would they would just be starting to get
focused on that one problem you know one
room in a building they'd be like no
send more guys into it send more guys
into it everyone's getting sprayed with
paint ball and put down in the training
operation and no it's two more guys and
eventually everyone's just you know it's
training but everyone's dead and they're
little it up and you just didn't they
got focused on and it cost them so the
leaders got to be able to step back and
detach and take a look at the situation
and decide you know what I'm gonna go
ahead and change course right now I'm
not gonna quit but I'm gonna just make a
strategic adjustment yeah and that's
it's weird how those semantics can
really change your outlook on the whole
task when you when you use the word quit
versus disengage or yeah another one
with quit like I said is give up you
know give it up I mean unless it's
something negative like smoking or
something like that you quit smoking
you're gay I'm gonna give up smoking
that's good
but obviously smoking is negative but
any kind of task or anything that
requires effort if you quit or
quote-unquote give up it's like it's
hard to have that sound like a good
thing you know yeah and one thing that's
this is you know obviously it applies to
combat it applies to jujitsu as we just
saw poplin also you know you look at
what you're doing day to day and the
little things in your life that you're
trying to make work or in a business
that you're trying to make something
happen
and sometimes people get so addicted to
their plan yeah make it so their ego is
wrapped around their plan their plan is
like 50% 50% tactics and technique and
it's 50% their own ego and so when you
try when that person
plan starts to fail guess what they
don't want to let it go cuz it's all
wrapped up in the rego so they just push
it further push it further they push it
further and especially if that person is
in a senior position
well then everyone's kind of just
followed in line and they're looking at
him they don't know they all know when
they're at the bottom of the chain of
command they're all looking at this
person saying hey buddy it's not working
let's disengage and fall back and figure
out a new plan of attack and then let's
reappropriation ship
and you've got a situation where you're
trying to make something work a certain
way and it's not maybe it's got a
disengage hey I've got to come with a
different angle of attack so you can get
the big wind in the long run yeah and
with relationships obviously it's it's
it's the same dynamic but it's different
because what's the same because when
you're in a let's say a
boyfriend/girlfriend relationship
whatever you been husband life you say
it's not working it saves one of them's
abusive right meanwhile the other ones
trying to quote-unquote make it work and
if they end up leaving all you gave up
on him you know you were you you quit
not and I don't think you'd ever say
you'd quit the relationship but you know
we'll just say you gave up on the
relationship right you know whoa he's
been abusing her for ten years already
you know we're in your case 27 years you
know whatever the number is and and you
got a I do not abuse my wife all right
right but you know as far as your
numbers go 27 but again like if you say
oh you gave up on the relationship it's
kind of like it's kind of like it's the
girl's fault a little bit like maybe she
she she shouldn't have done that almost
you know but yeah you disengage and if
you wanna if you want to go for the win
in that relationship and if you really
want to maintain the relationship don't
let it be a husband-wife relationship
maybe go back to being neighbors or
something like that even though in an
abusive relationship that might not work
but I'm just saying theoretically yeah
I'm not sure about all that
I'm sure man but I do know that if you
find yourself trying repeatedly to make
something happen and it's not happening
try a different route yeah don't
consider yourself a quitter consider
yourself a tech strategist or a
tactician